if we just look at the opinion poll for
sky news
just one result tells you the big
picture do people think that there was a
christmas party in number 10 last last
year or not look at the results here
yes
64 percent think a party did pla take
place nine percent think it did not take
place and uh something in the region of
27
uh say they do not know in other words
less than one in ten believe downing
streets denials the poll also shows that
they don't believe uh that covert rules
were
uh followed they don't believe uh that
boris johnson is telling the truth uh
now this is very serious this is why
downing street is having to take action
today
many of the people who were surveyed by
opinion will have been spoken to
online last night or this morning
they'll just have been getting to grips
uh with that video from itv news showing
downing three aides joking about the
alleged party
and clearly that has had an impact it
has had a cut through and it suggests
that boris johnson's denials are simply
not where most of the public are and
that's a problem it's a problem for
boris johnson in relation to the public
and it's a problem for boris johnson in
relation to his party look at this tweet
from former scottish conservative leader
ruth davidson she says none of this is
remotely defensible not having busy
boozy not parties while others were
sticking to the rules unable to visit
ill or dying loved ones nor flat out
denying things that were easily provable
not taking the public for fools and
today's we'll investigate what we've
spent a week saying didn't happen and
disciplined staff for rules we continue
to say weren't broken was pathetic as a
tory i was brought up to believe in
playing with a straight back believe me
colleagues are furious at this too so
what you heard boris johnson do earlier
was ask the cabinet secretary simon case
to investigate what happened in downing
street on december the 18th but not any
of the other occasions where there are
allegations of christmas parties either
in the offices of downing street or
indeed in boris johnson's own private
flat where he lives with mrs johnson
carrie johnson so quite a limited scope
downing street weren't able to say
whether or not uh the cabinet sector
will be able to report this side uh of
christmas uh they defended uh the fact
that they weren't looking into other
parties simply by saying the prime
minister addressed that in prime
minister's questions i'm not sure he did
but the anger amongst this party are
palpable they want to see heads roll
and that's why i wouldn't uh rule out
there being quite a rapid review and
some action taken within days